[Musique]
sesmat chambre froide où on entrepose
les humbles pour des pommiers et des
poiriers des pruniers des jeunes
desnoyers il y aussi des milliers
d'arbres qui iront bientôt cent à signer
ailleurs dans cette pépinière de
chaudière appalaches les ventes ont
grimpé de 40% l'an dernier et on
s'attend à une autre hausse pour - v
pour cent cette année c'est la folie
pour c'est le cash flow peau depuis la
pandémie du rub rotation là chaque année
pour répondre à la demande on a doublé
la superficie des seins
dès l'automne dernier la grande majorité
de la production était déjà réservé en
vue du printemps dépêchez vous si vous
voulez en avoir il en reste encore un
petit peu mais les ventes ne diminue
vraiment impressionné la vitesse les
gens réservent cette année l'eau dès le
mois de décembre janvier avait beaucoup
de ruptures de stock oui encore un peu
de choix évidemment mais pour des tubes
pitot mais en ce moment
c'est surtout les arbres fruitiers qui
ont la cote la récolte est en quelque
sorte une récompense une activité
familiale qu'on peut faire dans sa
propre cour la part des niches parce
qu'elle a eu une influence vraiment
significative sur l'intérêt des gens
pour l'horticulture le retour à la page
[Musique]
même si la neige n'a pas encore
complètement fondu certains se
précipitent déjà pour acheter leurs
semences
cette cliente ne veut pas répéter
l'expérience de l'an dernier je me suis
promis on avait un peu moins de cinq ans
et tout ça donc je voulais tout d'abord
ce que je voulais
10 les carottes concombres en fin de
semaine encore les piments
dans ce centre de jardinage on se
prépare pour le coup d'envoi de la
saison
d'ici la mi-avril cette serre sera
remplie d'arbres de plantes de fleurs et
de clients qui sont que le par rapport à
il ya deux ans c'est vraiment
impressionnant mais ils viennent tous en
même temps
le nombre de clients a bondi de 20%
depuis le début de la pandémie
et certains ont déjà passé leurs
commandes
beaucoup beaucoup de végétaux qui sont
réservées des gens qui on part de pas en
avoir aucune à part qu'on a un manque
qui réserve tout de suite qu'ils sont
même prêts à payer tout de suite pour
les avoir la pauvre quant au mois de
juillet au mois d'aout les fleurs
annuelles le lit plein de légumes ces
produits 100 % au québec ce alors il n'y
a pas de problème pour que nos
producteurs répondre à la demande cette
année même chose le poly vivace
après deux ans de pandémie les
producteurs horticoles de la province se
sont adaptés aux promet qu'il n'y aura
pas de pénurie ici olivier cachin
radio-canada saint juliet
[Musique]